les affaires françaises maintenant avec
tout d'abord cette information assez
étonnante qui divise la ville de
versailles qui ne devrait pas tarder à
créer une sujet de polémique dans tout
le pays c'est l'affectation d'une aile
entière du château de versailles des
logements type hlm vous dire que le
bâtiment était désaffecté depuis que la
ville a besoin de logements
mais cet après-midi un certain nombre de
manifestants ne m'ont pas du tout
entendu de cette oreille
jérôme monier a mené une enquête on met
les festes de cuisinière ici sur la
place d'armes
depuis que les versailles et au tapis
qu'une partie du château de versailles
allez être transformé en immeuble à
loyer modéré pour accueillir des
logements hlm
cette décision a été prise conjointement
par l'office des hlm et par les
monuments historiques dans le cadre de
la campagne pour la réhabilitation des
immeubles anciens
inutile de vous dire que cette décision
est fort controversé ici et si vous ne
voulez bien nous allons ouvrir assemble
ses dossiers brûlants
c'est de cette aile nord qu'il s'agit là
elle des ministres 1 construite par
mansart et restaurer au 19ème une aile
fermée aux visiteurs qui abrite
maintenant les pompiers
les travaux ont commencé pour y aménager
77 logements sociaux auxquels on
accédera bien sûr par la rue je trouve
tout à fait lamentable que tout les
bâtiments anciens beaux connu soit
soient vidées de leurs de leur sens que
leur destination et se transformer en en
lieux morts je le ressens comme ça en
tout cas
pouvez vous nous donner une idée du
contenu de ce projet oui bien sûr alors
les pièces du premier étage qui ont une
hauteur sous plafond très importantes
doivent être aménagés en duplex en
sous-sol nous aurons quelques salles de
réunion et celle de jeux pour les
enfants
et puis bien sûr il faut aussi
transformer au moins une partie du parc
qui l'a encore été conçu pour que le roi
sa course et invités évolué pour eux
pour s'adapter aux besoins des nouveaux
habitants
c'est à dire petit jardin conçu gère où
chacun pourra planter ses légumes
ces fleurs et où un contact avec la
nature très proche pour être établie le
comité national de défense du château a
été constitué il a déjà réuni 25 mille
deux cents signatures à travers la
france ait déposé un recours en conseil
d'état
pour nous il s'agit maintenant d'une
course contre la monte quand il s'agit
d'obtenir l'annulation du décret de
déclassement avant que les gens mon
ménage on comprenait bien qu'on pourra
pas les expulser après nous avons
justement rencontré dans un immeuble
insalubre du vieux versailles l'un des
futurs locataires veilleur de nuit 29
ans père célibataire vivant depuis cinq
ans dans 15 mètres carrés avec ses deux
fils donc j'ai fait une demande aux hlm
et puis je viens de recevoir une une
lettre que j'ai reçue il ya trois jours
me disant donc que j'avais jallet avait
bénéficié d'un appartement etc 3
et dans le château de versailles ah ben
oui dans château de versailles
moi c'est moi ça m'est égal si vous
voulez moi ce que je cherche c'est un
logement parce que vraiment avec les
petits surtout vous avez vu apporter aux
idées il ya même en plus déçus des
fuites lorsqu'il se met à pleuvoir c'est
très très commode extrait ça dure on
devait voir ménagers alors ça je ne sais
pas j'ai téléphoné donc lorsque j'ai
reçu la lettre et on m'a vite que arrête
ta vrai qu'on m'a dit que je pouvais
emménager d'ici six mois un an
voilà la seule chose que je puisse vous
dire à ce stade du journal c'est de ne
plus appeler pour tenir des logements
dans cette veine puisque vous venez de
l'entendre il ya une procédure qui est
en cours